hallo das ist mein offizielles lieber
und lina bewerbungsvideo lisa und lena
falls ihr das seht ich kann auch musik
machen und ich kann auch meine lippen
zur musik bewegen
hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal
waren und heute mache ich meinen wurzeln
alle ehre und zwar gleich ein video von
karlsbad die gerade hat hochgeladen hat
das könnt ihr hier sehen und zwar hat
sie bei instagram direkt mal in ihre
nachrichten reingeguckt und entdeckt
dass da leute ihr schreit und dann habe
ich mal bei ihm zu glauben sagen ich
weiß jetzt wie das model 96 anfragen
geklickt und gemerkt dass die leute auch
geschrieben habe und jetzt kommt der
moment keiner gewandelt hat ich werde
die messages beantworten wo ihr könnt
mir auch im freundin hat wieder richtig
heiße dort mal was für ein wunder ich
habe noch keine nachricht angeklickt und
wäre jetzt einfach mal die
entschuldigung dass ich mir etwas
reagiert habe ich wusste wirklich mich
dass ich so viele nachrichten bekommen
und hanne du hast mit deinem video mal
ein t shirt mit dem personal wappen von
harry potter getan
würdest du mir sagen woher gesetzt hat
ich liebe deine videos und deine tattoo
ich glaube das ist der perfekte
zeitpunkt um euch mal was zum beispiel
die besucher eine menge geschafft von
harry potter oder adventure time oder
anderen nötigen starb und diese t-shirts
sind von primark ich weiß man darf mich
beim einkaufen und ich glaube auch
wirklich nichts anderes zeug weil man
nur diese blöden nötigen titel cool
vendor marketer immer neue coole potter
wachen und so und es tut mir so leid und
es heißt jedes mal wird vom körper trage
fragen mich viele leute wo ihr es habt
und jedes mal sage ich jetzt nicht
weiter gehen nein ich will den leuten
nicht sagen dass ich das total cup und
jetzt ist die große lüge trauten ok
beleidigt mich ich habe es verdient
aber denk dran und ganz ehrlich sie sind
nicht beliebig von h&m und bayern dann
kaufe ich auch ein und habe ich euch
jetzt verraten leiden schreibt hey kann
ich mal fragen woher du deinen
lederhalsband hast sieht sehr hübsch aus
was sie noch verrieten lederhalsband
sagen möchte ich hatte das internet
laden beruht mit honig video an und ganz
viele von euch haben geschrieben das ist
das schwarze gürtel dings
katar ist ja wirklich nicht
nicht in wurden kopf aber ihnen viele
leute darauf reagiert haben hier zum
kleinen schwarzen streifen an hubble
leute das ist ein ganz normales und ich
bin ein hund ist auch nur schwer ist das
jetzt leicht eine sehr komische frage
aber heißt du mit nachnamen
ich kannte mal so eine die so wie du
aussiehst ist schon ein paar jahre her
dass ich es nicht mehr genau
und auch wenn es sehr heiß wird bist du
denn jetzt wirklich die story erzählen
ich hab mal ein apples dort gemacht also
freiwilliges soziales jahr und das habe
ich nachmittags import gemacht und
vormittags in der ersten klasse bei uns
in der nähe einer schule das mädchen
geschrieben hat ist einfach ein kind aus
der ersten klappe was ich halt betreut
haben
aber es lohnt sich folglich mit einer
special price zu gucken wo er eine frage
welche nationalität bist du ich bin
deutscher nationalität aber habe noch
politische wurzeln und italienische
wurzeln in mir drin italienische wurzeln
weil die großeltern irgendwie hat dann
italien bahn von einer seite und
polnische weil meine eltern aus polen
kommen deshalb bestehe ich auf drei
wunderbaren komponenten und sehe aus wie
aussehen und ich kann auch polnisch
alles verstehen ich kann es ok sprechen
und italien leider gar nicht die senior
das war spanisch französisch keine
ahnung wie italien steht die zahl
spaghetti bolognese café latte
cappuccino espresso bei ihrer wahl keine
antwort aber vielleicht machst du ja mal
ein video also du hast dich wirklich mit
trifft will der senat steht nun ich
hoffe es stört mich nicht so krass aber
ich möchte dir auf jeden fall sagen dass
mir das leisten weil die beiden beide
einfach total leid und ich frage wie du
damit zurechtkommt aber die scheint es
ja ganz gut zu gehen hier geht es
tatsächlich ganz gut ich glaube manchmal
hat man herr trennungen die einen länger
schmerzhaft sind aber wenn man sich halt
im guten trend auch bei uns der fall war
dann tut es nicht so richtig sagen wenn
man hier auch weiterhin gut versteht und
schon irgendwie sowas wie freunde ist
also nach einer trennung ist sperrig
freunde zu seinem enkel vielleicht
ergibt sich ein paar jahren immer mal
wieder
aber wenn man wirklich sehen kann und
ganz normal unterhalten kann und ich
meine katzen immer wieder beim kuscheln
gehen kann dann ist es so perfekt und
tatsächlich alles supergut wir fangen
jetzt überhaupt nicht aufgesetzt oder
nein ich möchte unbedingt mal deine füße
in sneakers onken sehen ich finde deine
füße total schön dass du bekommst du
meine füße nicht in sneaker socken
arbeiten sneaker und socken jedem es
eine jeder verbraucher möchte aber bitte
keine solche anfragen denn kommt - gut
an ja ok liebe grüße hamburg die kritik
zurück jetzt noch eine position finden
in der ich gemütlich witze ja auch nicht
das ist gemütlich bon giorno einfordern
not da sind wir wieder beim
italienischen weißt du das hier das
schreib ich weil es amüsante zwar ein
bisschen zeit habe ich mir diese
verrückte apps hinter geladen eine
affekthandlung weil das mit meinem baby
girl auseinandergegangen
jedenfalls war ich dich dort werde ich
euch schon mal mit tat gestanden habe
dann kann ich euch jetzt auch noch
verraten ja ich war bei kindern hab ich
da angemeldet hat ein bisschen behindert
mich aber mit niemandem getroffen und
ich mit einer person habe ich das werde
ich gut geschrieben und auf englisch das
hat nicht ganz witzig aber ich hätte da
ist leider nichts um mich ich hab nicht
so cool da denke ich habe ich darüber
nachgedacht das jetzt so sein muss wenn
jemand der mich kennt auf mein video
ich bin damit nicht ob das irgendwie
diverse oder auch ich mit dem schreiben
für mich dann eigentlich auf youtube
plant und dann aber nicht verrät und
dann später sich herausstellt sind sie
gerade richtig ehrliche pässe pro fall
wert ist weiß solide leistung paper
company jetzt youtube und co
enjoy ich möchte bitte keine lang kaufen
diese leute sind mir ziemlich schöne
geld aber dann trotzdem wirklich ist
unwichtig wie kannst mit leicht zu
kaufen
bring dich nicht voran das ist einfach
nur bleibt aber noch nicht aufgefallen
buchbar titel minor
die hülle was die super trägt ist wenn
dann der bus controller kommt braucht
einfach nur auf deinem handy kontrollen
zu zeiten vor
und ansonsten ruhig halt immer ewig
danach live acts mit vanessa auch durch
anscheinend nur tragen zu meinen füßen
bekommen habe werde ich jetzt mal bei
instagram die leute dazu aufrufen jedoch
ein paar fragen zu stellen hallo leute
ich drehe gerade ein video in dem ich
verklagt dann schreib mir einfach wäre
praktiker jetzt müssen wir ganz gut auf
antworten warten nehmen denn du hast du
schon mal drogen genommen
gute frage nächste frage sportlich hat
kaffee getrunken
ich habe schon mal zigaretten geraucht
und ich habe schon mal alkohol getrunken
also ja ich habe schon mal drogen
genommen alles andere was man noch unter
drogen gezeichnet das noch nicht wie
komme ich natürlich keine probe zu
nehmen
das hat nichts mit moral oder so
zuversichtlich angst vor drogen zu
nehmen weil alkohol werden deine sinne
ja schon so getrübt und bei allen
anderen drogen wie speed kokain war
nicht alles gibt kaum ich nicht was mit
meinen körper oder was mit mir passieren
würde wenn ich diese drogen nehmen würde
derzeit lasse ich davon komplett die
finger und ich glaube bis 45 damit ganz
gut gelaufen da hast du derzeit einen
freund ja habe ich
kelly ist mein freund roger ist mein
freund und ich hab noch ganz viele
andere freunde verwandte meine frage
könntest du wenn du fertig mit dem
renovieren will ist eine tour machen
werde euch alles zeigen denn ich bin
viel zu stolz darauf meine wohnung
gerade so super sammler wird wie viele
bauchnabel zeiten hast du auch nabel
zeiten 123 was ist eigentlich ein ding
katzen die haben wir gekocht und so ein
richtig leckeren braten draus gemacht da
ich mich haben wollte und mein ex
partner auch mädchen haben wir uns
gesagt essen wir sie einfach ihr heim
wäre ein bisschen zu viel reis dachten
wir
und ja sie gegessen kann ich das video
beenden
kannst du und sammelt hoffe ich dass ich
viel spaß hatte und wünsche euch einen
traumhaften tag lasst es euch gut gehen
lassen
gute wetter auf die stimmung
regen lassen hier gibt's noch mal meine
füße für euch und hier gibt's noch mehr
videos zum anschauen abonnieren könnt
ihr mich kriegt man kelly danke für die
tolle video idee auf instagram lohnt
sich denn ich bin eine basic wird die
besten bilder macht das nächste mal
manchen video umliegenden idee bis dann